bonjour à tous on est aujourd'hui sur le
stand 2 wiseur directement procès s et
ils sont sortis un tout nouveau
organisateurs qui est connecté
georges tron alors
[Musique]
m
en sortie oui le disons que c'est un
prototype c'est un produit qui pourrait
effectivement on jamais voir le jour
parce que on sait que ces réserves ya
vraiment des produits
develop quittait ce qu'ils essayent mais
qu'au final ne sortent jamais sans
marcher alors qu'est ce que ce produit
est vraiment exceptionnel à tout
simplement
c'est l'espèce d'ordinateurs coquille
avec un clavier avec un écran dans
lequel vous allez revanche est posé au
centre votre réseau fon comme un espèce
de trackpad
c'est un truc qui est vraiment
intelligente parce que vous allez
exploiter la puissance du réseau punk
qui est vraiment hyper puissant je n'ai
jamais parlé dans une précédente vidéo
d'ailleurs je vous invite à aller voir
vous avez effectivement 8 gigas de ram
vous avez une bête de course sur un
trottoir agissements complètement dingue
donc vous allez vous avez qu à bloguer
votre smartphone dedans et il va servir
en réalité de coeur à votre ordinateur à
cette espèce de grande coquille
donc l'idée c'est que lorsque vous avez
besoin d'un ordinateur d'un vous prenez
vous branchez sol et vous prenez vous
branchez vous posez dedans et lorsque
vous voulez je dirais
un smartphone vous prenez vous partez ça
fait penser un petit peu aux ex qu'on
peut retrouver chez samsung s'est pas
exactement la même chose si vous lui et
avec le decs vous allez uniquement
reposer votre sanction d'autres déçus de
notre futur est neuf directement dedans
vous avez un écran un clavier une souris
là c'est vraiment un ordinateur portable
vous pouvez emmener partout avec vous et
qui va utiliser la puissance du réseau
fon donc c'est vraiment un truc de
dingue c'est super intéressant donc
c'est un concept qui gagne peut-être
jamais joué en attendant on peut dire
c'est quelque chose qui est vraiment
prometteur c'est vraiment une super idée
de se dire que quand finale est-ce que
les smartphones ne trouve pas aussi réel
intérêt avec le coeur d'un ordinateur
vous auriez tous dans vos données avec
vous vos paris sportifs soit au travers
du smartphone soit sur un ordinateur
donc c'est vraiment intéressant termes
de réflexion c'est vraiment passionnant
sollicitations des risques auster le
produire pour vraiment son pesant de
cacahuètes donc j'espère qu'il verra le
jour
parce qu'ils ont vraiment des produits
super innovant c'est super intéressant
ça ne méritait vraiment le fait d'aider
non pas l'abandonner au csc prodigue été
énormément récompensé tient vraiment au
mieux pour vous serez plus dessus parce
que quelque chose de super innovant
tu penses que vous conscient commentaire
est nul ça c'est quelque chose qui a de
l'avenir qui pourrait vous intéresser
marquis mois d'une sentence que je pense
que ce soit de vraiment super
intéressant vous remercie d'avoir gardé
cette vidéo comme d'habitude vous invite
à mener sa dépouille à vous abonner pour
parler toujours plus et toujours mieux
d'être restez connectés à très bientôt
louise ou yahoo